you know when you know it's not going
well for some after the game Grant
started talking about man my mom and my
daddy taught me my man started talking
about the morals and values that he grew
up on like bro you just got dropped off
by Jimmy Butler like we didn't question
how you was raised my dog they were
losing the league energy was gone like
he hit Trey and started talking crazy as
much as we all want to blend Grant
Williams that ain't Grant Williams fault
like Grant Williams supposed to do that
like when you do that yeah you do got to
stand on that and of course you're gonna
hear it like ain't no passes but you
then need JT and JB they're like come on
now turn it into gear and cover your man
yeah after the game they actually saved
me about Grant and poking the bear or
whatnot and he said next question to me
I'm like oh they done you can't next
question to JB the Celtics quit